ah damn bro ya full get up huh bro I
just stepped off the set you know I'm
saying and I and I don't have time so I
just let you drop the psoriasis and all
huh yeah I got well they they paint my
psoriasis down and then I got I got my
tube socks I got my thighs y'all got the
tight shorts you got the Reebok dad
shoes I got the real loser in it so
you'd be surprised I'm wearing the easy
dad shoes he's really similar huh
oh my god it's you generation that's it
those are dog leash shoes I've ever seen
that you're wearing right now they
terrible yeah they're the worst super
comfortable I know these are hot - man
yeah man - dad shoes the dad looks in
that dad looks that's the whole getup
huh yeah this is all good anyone say
anything when you walked in I'll wear
this show this show goes ten years I
wear this show that's what that's what I
will sure it's you don't did this is it
I better get used to this and in the
wintertime when you're in the studio's
and it's you know it's 50 degrees you're
in this it's not fun especially the
morning time is that a UH was this oh we
go watch uh yep you know what you know
what dude it's a Seiko good job this is
this is what people wore in the eighties
and nineties well that's right yeah it's
cool man thanks bro
so got a little makeup on my face see
you let me do me smooth skin it got good
skin I'll leave it on though that's
right
had to do a lot of my own stunts today
like dunk a basketball off jump off a
pad and then don't get there was some
stuff going on yeah very it's been going
good it's been going good a lot of work
a lot of repetition you know how acting
is my friend okay no short days no short
days and how many weeks do you guys
shoot we got 13 episodes Brennan so
three weeks on one week off and so one
episode one week that's correct sir
that's quick now 30 sometimes you get a
director sometimes you get a DP a
director or a photographer photography
he wants to use his own lenses he's got
to change the lenses out things take
more time he wants the shot to look
beautiful
that's gonna take that's gonna take you
into some some some late hours sometimes
dead a little annoying
well bet a little bit can you have your
trailer on there got my trailer boring
of those trailers there my trailer is a
modest trailer and there's not much to
do in that trailer there's a chair this
big mirror there's a bathroom that's it
the couch craft services this crowd I
use a lot of craft
it's nice yeah he they they make me my
own coffee they're little things like
that it's nice it's the little things
yeah dude I was thinking about it I mean
our last episode was a fun one that was
a fun one by the fun one that was a fun
I always have a good time it's a fun one
trying to figure out chin doing TV shows
carry on nothing compares to podcast
it really doesn't it doesn't yeah what
do you think man you seem like you're
reminiscing man you seem like you're
looking look like you're looking off
well I was just I don't we've come a
long ways man yeah thinking about turn
we were young bucks in this game and you
have psoriasis and I just shaved head
and sure no spots on my dick yeah those
were the days bro is where the date will
be at this fancy studio yeah a Korean
producer and you're all diseases yeah
for all that stuff wear a purple Porsche
came along for Tesla came for Tesla in
purple had a cold roll way how strive
and I was driving a Prius on a red
Barcelona red god those remember those
were the days but like you'd go back and
then I was thinking about it tuned
when's the last time we sang a song you
know some before you tell mother it's
big big dick bandit big big bandits big
big bands yeah Caribbean daga and a big
brown bear know what I can't forget that
one me too Caribbean tiger big brown
bear something like that honey nobody
well I can't remember get some what
about you know I can't remember that for
some of our other James
oh is it big big big big man its
Caribbean tiger
those were the hits those were the hits
those for the hits like we're kind of
one-hit wonders but then we had
Caribbean Tigers sometimes I like you
know about dialy around with a song like
I got it on the shower yeah I wrote a
song called egg sticks you know what I
mean it's show about dicks big sticks
it's show about dicks dicks dicks cuz
they know about dicks dicks dicks dicks
see there's a that's how it starts I
don't know you know it's a show about
dicks dicks dicks it's show about dicks
dicks is cuz we know about dicks dicks
dicks we have girls on the dish we got
pearls in our next year and heard of her
dicks
we got words burn dicks like dong like
bang like peace like Liz like hago so
I don't want to say it says like meat
puddle I don't want to say that why dude
that makes me feel safe
like meat pod like like pod rock dicks
grow big like giant dolls [ __ ] hangs low
like Brian's ball hey dick like a peach
pit or a big dick black make a hole quit
like Devin Booker is dead yeah got a
small dick black bee spit not gonna big
dick make a hole quit if you listen to
the show you know that all dicks are
created and created equal some dicks are
straight up evil
now our horse sticks out kill people
hands on hands on hands there you go for
our hands bro I don't know Jim what you
think do you think that song it's really
good I think you put a country twang on
that yeah I think I could do a little
bit of everyone your entire musical
career
you got your guitar yeah I do can you
lead us into oil [ __ ] you lead us into a
song here maybe I didn't really do this
I don't practice but let's see if this
will work so all right
[Music]
this guy's a feel-good song did it's a
show about dicks dicks dicks dicks dicks
dicks it's a show about dicks dicks
dicks so much better than dick stick
sticks we got an old Amish dicks dicks
got pearls on our dicks
you ain't heard about dicks ain't heard
about dicks
we got words for dicks flag down like
Wayne like peas like slang like lizard
like hucko so like meat bud bozo bozo
I don't know so bro sorry I'm do you
made it so much better chin I now got a
small dick like a peach pit her big dick
may go oh quit
if you listen to the show you know that
all dicks ain't created equal some dicks
are straight up evil
I got horse dicks that'll kill people
take sticks it's a show about days do
you ever get do you ever get those dams
or emails people like dudes you gotta
quit talking about that no I don't
either
I don't either dude's gone dude master
never stop talking about dicks it's just
guys every time a woman I think I have
this like a professional woman in the
industry Oh what are your pikas I'd love
to listen where I go now you know I told
you I was in line at alfred's and the
guy goes bro your dude you're you're
from finally can i yeah what's up man
you know trying to keep it down like
yeah what's up man his buddy goes what I
don't know who I am do I know who that
is yes yeah yeah I know you've heard he
is that show about dicks and all these
people - I'm like nope
well no it that's nice you know you're
kind of right kind of right we're really
right we're amateur we're super immature
dude I spent I can't believe I'm such a
dad I'm such a [ __ ] pop grown dad I
had to go remember him remember my sons
in please going to preschool starts
preschool Monday and whatever reason l8
how does its competitive to get into
preschool you can matter when you pay
the tuition paid for [ __ ] preschools
ridiculous in LA I'm sure around other
areas of this lovely nation and so we're
on this waiting list and Tigers gone
through the pre preschool at this one
place and then that has to transfer over
they only take a certain amount of kids
and there's two there's they don't take
30 kids and there's two slots the
morning slot and afternoon slot yep
well you want the morning slot every
what's the morning slot the afternoon
slot sucks for parents because of many
many reasons especially for me in the
morning sack and I work in there in that
night so my afternoons are the block
that I need spend the time with my son
so I wake up with them breakfast you
always think go to work come home after
noon spend time with them put him to bed
then I go to work with stand-up or
shooting one of my shows that's the
routine man
so what happens big day homeboy eats
afternoon they put him in the afternoon
class man I spent an afternoon class I
went through this - we're on the street
is John Legend's son took your spot huh
well that's what happens well you know
what he's more talent than me I get it
that's fine if we're gonna play that
game so I had to stop on out to mosey on
over and pay a little visit to the
principal today you did yep
hit the button who is it it's Brendan
Schaub whoo Tigers dad
oh oh okay come on in she was what can
we help you Tigers actually not here for
another two hours right I know I'm here
to see you she's in the middle of lunch
right how's your lunch sat down said
here's the thing it's going on here so I
explained it to her and out is the rate
you as I'm explaining my reason for why
he needs to go the morning class
I'm like I'm talking my son's [ __ ]
principal I'm I'm gonna gag I'm a dad
it's just some dad [ __ ]
yeah I've dad shoes on yeah I hit these
[ __ ] stonewashed jeans I'm probably
gonna head back worried about my ficuses
this is some dad [ __ ] right now man
you're worried about your [ __ ] yeah in
the middle I'm in the middle of this
[ __ ] and I'm going through with this
lady and then you know older lady and
I'm thinking I'm after greases old old
bat's palms I'm out to grease the pump I
said what if I make the wrong offer
she's like excuse me we will not
tolerate that here at this establishment
see ya then we get kicked out yeah so I
just tried thought I went I don't I
don't know when you do here's my
schedule I I need time my son you put
him there because I get a John Legend
beautiful song print of our generation
right he's great amazing here's the
thing though I don't know and this is
embarrassing you know it I don't know if
there's a donation I can make of some
sort to figure this out you guys have
bills hey Shirley good what I went you
say New York progressive you guys have
bill shoes what are you talking about
what no oh I thought you guys did like a
fundraiser and all I'm saying is I
appreciate I [ __ ] I could read the
road back that no I'm what I'm trying to
say is if you have the fundraiser I'm
going to donate three to the cars
because I like what you guys do here and
if you pull me there any class that'd be
great and she goes have a good day on it
thanks I was it that was it shut you
down my I hope I get a call two hours
later
do I sent an email followed up with an
email like a gentleman went here's the
problem put out this whole sad story
which is all true and then two hours
later she went hey we actually had a
panic cancel so we got a man thank God
but I thought I'm greasing old bat's
palms this isn't New York in the six no
sky no world doesn't work this way guy I
know named al he was a guy who literally
a guy I met him one time and he goes sir
PEC deck sir PEC deck and gym you know I
can get it I can't find a solid PEC deck
who's that guy knew you a guy you know
great guy had come over to be an actor
for a while it didn't work out you know
really a nice guy and I wasn't there but
his friends said that al got arrested I
go having us he got pulled over with his
buddy
and there was a girl with him right so
he wanted impress a girl I got this
don't worry about it cop La Casa [ __ ]
around the button-down cop shows up in
asserts jars license to me goes like
this you guys yeah not a problem here's
my driver's license that's 100 if it
comes back it doesn't it doesn't come
back it doesn't come back with the
license
tacos excuse me sir
because it doesn't come back it doesn't
come back conkers is this a bribe sir
and he goes bribe to donation doesn't
work the car service work done it's a
lie quiet doesn't walk around we don't
know it is there anything worse we get
shot shot down like that God ever my god
ever one time I got pulled when I was I
was going in or now trying to meet Todd
Phillips for I was late with my wife and
I was we were trying to get to have
dinner with ourselves I was late way to
go be yeah of course right as usual
and I'm like fool and cop it takes an
off-duty cop and he goes hey he goes
what are you doing
I've been watching you do this insane
stuff what are you doing I go I know I'm
really sorry I'm going to meet somebody
I can't be late he goes ok but I'm a
police officer and I just saw you make
about 20 different violations I go I did
I did I'm that panicked and he goes
alright well do me a favor if I see do
it again I'm gonna pull you over and I'm
off duty right now and I'm gonna give
you the ticket of your life I'm like I'm
sorry and he goes yeah and he goes
alright I go hey dude listen can I get
any you like comedy
you like stand-up comic
I go come to my show I'll I'll give you
anytime you want and he goes no I can't
do that I can't tackle bro what just
what's your name tell me your name I'll
write it down here's my number he goes I
can't it would be a it would be against
my via my principles I was like ah [ __ ]
I never mind you know doing whatever I
could yeah you try to help me have you
ever had like you other words I mean
shot down or I'll get to that like
you're its what is special not a
singular slang the girls DMS are you
talking you take your shot and she's
like what what you don't know you know I
didn't mean that's so embarrassing
you misread signalled like in the day
and you thought she was oh my hey we
have a problem what are you thinking no
when I said you want to see my [ __ ]
that's autocorrect you wanna see my prop
my pride props cuz I'm an actor I didn't
get cop I didn't mean [ __ ] I met my
unsheath dog oh no I'm sorry
Autocar guts run when I say [ __ ] I met
my giant dick I meant I have no interest
in you as a person I just want to bang
you coz you're having no interest in the
skills you possess no super I may not go
out to dinner and pretend to listen to
you until I can get in your pants
because I'm sorry we did I blur the
lines there
let me help this out oh it's like that I
that that time was at Benihana and a
long time guys they're on a date [ __ ]
long time when I was in college I was on
a date night have enough money paid for
the food and drinks and the girls were
in all this [ __ ] I was like ah [ __ ] man
and I was next to an older dude who
played football and he also played at CU
and for the reason he was like oh you
play for the buff so we started talking
the guy didn't like 87 or so I'm like
that and you know at the time like okay
dinosaur anyways we're talking and okay
dinosaur fossil and he were talk and I
didn't think much of it and she's doing
all this [ __ ] and he can tell like my
demeanors like oh [ __ ] and she's like
guys you actually didn't have money ID
no no that's just so in other words you
were gonna have to be like can I not
from here I was like I don't know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna go in the back
and talk to manager like I was just me
like here's the prize I'm in college
this [ __ ] word like my time
and [ __ ] on we're at Benihana's I
didn't know you guys serve alcoholic
drinks I didn't know she was over 21 I
think she has a fake ID she's wearing
all this [ __ ] I don't have $30 Oh 30
like $3 I was just expecting to get some
nice [ __ ] fried rice this [ __ ]
weren't shrimp and flopster and
stressing me out
I don't have the balls the same thing
I'll wash dishes for the next three
weeks or whatever you want to do but
don't call me out man she's so hot I
thought about saying that and then when
the bill came everyone got theirs and I
didn't get one
I'm gonna call [ __ ] they they're
probably called the cops she's underage
or something like that and the guy
talking next to me took care of the bill
really he could have see sense like
water maybe he did it but he said
something was gonna cuz I'm sweating
bullets I shut down Jessica and I go you
wanna like no I mean like you wants to I
like no no no more drinks I got shutting
everything down so I can't afford it
this [ __ ] good fan IRA or good sort
of wearing my ties and [ __ ] get lucky
no she was terrible person anyways guy
paid for the bill thank God for that
fossil alumni paid the bill and then I
ran out so thankful I was so happy and
then I was at Benihana with my family
this is like I don't know a year or two
ago and there's a kid next to me him and
his girl and I saw them bust out a
coupon I saw him looking at coupons
because they're trying to figure out
what to order and I didn't want to be I
don't know if it was a first date on
what the [ __ ] was going on but I wanted
my cake get rid of the [ __ ] when I
got this man
but I don't want to embarrass from his
girl so they look at a coupon she's a
good spy only get one like going through
the things so they're on their food and
then you can tell he's like man maybe I
should get a drink and she's like well
we just we'd you did just get paid and
we have this much to spend and I was
like ah [ __ ] man
so then I went into the back of the
manager I gave him I currently am gonna
pay for those two next to me whatever
they order put it on my card whatever
they order well apparently they didn't
hear it but apparently they just spend
money like water and she started
ordering my the [ __ ] mai tais again
for five mai tais [ __ ] lobster I was
like this [ __ ] Hut man try and be a
good guy and she [ __ ] fires up the
menu that's it that she did it yeah
that's free all right I don't think they
knew it was free I just think they're
like hey you just got
paid young kids oh so they decided get a
little crazy they'll spend all their
paycheck on the place but then they're
like God took care of music dude I
really preach I'm like yeah that's one
did for me man but you're a dick but
yeah yeah it's a good feeling to be able
to do that for somebody that who really
needs it though yeah it's it's that's
kind of the idea wouldn't you have a lot
of money yeah I mean like what do you
have you have car payments I'll take
care of them for the next three years
that's what I'm saying if you're hot
enough yeah apartment I'm Pam what let
me take care of it yeah yeah I don't
know it gets tricky with those things it
does get tricky with those things man
you never know you had to pay it for
some page for your Starbucks or
something in front of you have you know
like to pay it forward thing or someone
they kill the person afraid take care of
it oh I don't want to I want it I want
to do it and then not see anybody yeah I
want to have to be like was that go
thank God no no no that was several
actors that I admire so one guy from the
wire who played the police captain you
know the giant black guy oh yeah he was
with his wife and I loved that show and
I loved him and so they were having
breakfast tonight I just bought him
breakfast I said tell my breakfast
burrito telephones from a fan now he's
actually a really nice breakfast all the
bit the big guy Wendell right no you're
not a detective not him if you keep
going and I love a man she can show such
a good actor Michael B Jordan was in it
yeah everybody was in them anyway but uh
but I remember just that that feeling
here and then he saw me oh that's him
there the bald guy Reggie Reggie okay no
yeah that's him this guy eyes Oh Isaiah
Whitlock is powerful must know know he's
Robert you kidding me appeal to the
other one it wasn't that one it's the
other one it's right there Robert Robert
yeah yeah oh yeah and he's in law and
order he's acknowledged stop great use
them all Lord since 1973 yes he's in
nineteen he's just a real actor thousand
seeing some real actor and it was just
like I just had respect for him
and I did that with George Carlin but I
got the [ __ ] out of there I did that
with Rob Reiner got the [ __ ] out of
there George Carlin was I'm at Cora's by
the way this is probably a month before
exactly a month
I mean Korres which is right at what age
74 he's young and he was right there
alone eating breakfast and I just went I
saw and I was there and I was like are
you talking about
he's my number one so I was like that's
George crotchety everyone's number one
be probably in a lot as long as long as
he's done it a new HBO model yeah he's
just Church crawling everyone else they
compare had these short runs he did it
furled well a great satirist man is just
a great you know comic and and I bought
him you know was what it was what it was
you know Rob won't Reiner another good
legend director and producer and was
eating its God
Jelena across from me at the communal
table I just liked about Rob Reiner
grown up Rob Weiner Rob Reiner goddammit
Robert Weiner brings up by know Bob
Weiner drink serious there's a cut a
legend I mean a legend a legend director
a legend producer a legend actor back in
the day was in anybody what was he and
what sitcom is he in he was in mama he
was in the movie by by love which is an
old school one know all in the family he
was using bye-bye love and then he's
also the therapist in office space that
goes one to has a heart attack and puts
him in a train I'm pretty sure I don't
remember I'm like it could be another
day probably I like I like the way
you're talking no mmm-hmm do do
therapist and off space as [ __ ] you that
you might they look similar they go to
images I was actually going to there
it's off space movie or film your honey
this guy that guy click out this is a
part I'm talking about
so hypnotherapy cubicle today in every
lie you tell me he they don't look
identify started working every single
day in my life has been worse than the
day before it isn't every single day
that you see me that's on the worst day
in my life what about the day
it's kind of looks like already I've
worked her back is messed up Cecil here
yeah what today worst day of my life
wow that's messed up there any way that
you could sort of just Zonk me out so
they're like I I don't know that I'm at
work my mom would say this all the time
could I come home and think that I've
been fishing all day something that's
really not what I do Peter however the
good news is I think office space top-10
zombies long time Jews great job great
hair Steven root I'm gonna easy can I
enjoy relax I can't talk to my mother
thought I talked to my diary that guy
come very lots to do every muscle in
your body
beginning with you know watch the any
other whole thing now we have both tapes
people don't tell us I got my fingers
103 to deeper and deeper still sweating
what's his I what just left I who's lots
of deeper on deeper way down
[Music]
[Music]
there's a few movies that I'd know so
goddamn well because I remember this
scene from office I was dude there's few
movies I know like the back of my hand
because when I was in training camp in
college whether it was here or in
university Colorado you know you I
didn't have cable so we had D I had just
had DVDs yeah so I just watch them over
and over about Billy Madison happy
gilmore office space [ __ ] gigolo with
Rob Schneider what's the one movie you
saw you ever seen a movie that made you
ache ache I love this no never never
like I'm not like uh-huh like that nope
never
there was one of these no the new Beauty
and the Beast God frozen no sir Little
Mermaid I'm dead inside now but when I
was young when I felt things no when I
was a row man are you like I don't I
don't like knuth like I have a regiment
right like I don't like trying new
things I'd like to go a new place is
that I don't like to really travel and
see new [ __ ] this was fine just google
it I like like I'll watch the same movie
over and over I like leaving a movie on
or show on that I've already seen and
then I close my eyes cuz it's the big
screen in my head so I can play the
movie over my head so we're really yeah
still oh yeah so you like what is it a
film
number I mean there's a there's like a
handful that where if it's on TV I will
watch every time yeah happy gilmore
Billy machination they're just they're
just certain things that's why humans
like a routine death yeah you're you're
good with the routine yeah you're good
with predictable routine yeah there's
nothing wrong with that at all my might
whole life has been the exact opposite
of that and I crave a routine
I can't you get it below you but even if
someone give you a routine I feel like I
don't put you in a bright like an
[ __ ] bracket you freak the [ __ ] out
problem you think you want that probably
but I do want it you do need like you're
like that wild horse and put in the
like [ __ ] this yeah but I recognize that
that because when we do show well
depends you know kid you know controlled
chaos because when you and I do shows
together right I'd always want to get
there early we go over everything I try
out the last second make let's go over a
mic dude I freak the [ __ ] out yeah so
we're just it like I like like I was set
tonight at the store right so I'll get
there early I'll go over my set
word-for-word
in the back in the mirror and then I'll
go up and do this brian's that he just
show he does yeah that just my whole
[ __ ] childhood was that way it was so
crazy chaotic yeah that I think that so
chaotic though well I don't know let's
see my dad would that would come home
and go wearily we're moving to Greece
say goodbye to your dog I hope you guys
enjoyed Pakistan I'll tell you what
we're gonna we're gonna have I'm gonna
ma we're to you in Manila
let's stay there for a year let's go to
uh let's go to Calcutta you guys gonna
hang there for about a year and a half
now you're probably at all kinds of
leggett here get a whole bunch of shots
let's move over to Bombay alright India
we just cross over here let's stay there
for a little while
don't worry about it let's go to state
places now let's go to Lebanon let's go
to Lebanon well hang in Lebanon but now
I'm done with Lebanon let's go to let's
go to Pakistan he's ready for box on but
you're gonna get a dog your dog you will
keep that dog for batty here cuz kids
don't get attached to their dogs at all
man
say bye to all your friends and your dog
this is a good year and a half we're
gonna move back to Lebanon whoa
Lebanon's awesome but hold on guys I
know you're loving this it's fantastic
schools good and everything else you got
some hamsters we can't have a dog but
we'll get some hamsters by the way it
can troubled hamsters you know the war
just broke out and why don't you come
down with a case of hepatitis a now well
I need you to do is I'm gonna leave dad
that's gonna leave now dad can't get
back in the country but you guys hang
out here for a long while and live in
the Holiday Inn sleep on the floor cuz
the war on bullets were afraid it's
gonna go on Oh though but you know what
why don't you guys go down to the
underground garage and hang out again
over there he would like couldn't you
couldn't have a home in the States and
he knows the traveling no sir why
because
his job required that he I know but why
did you guys that white here's like days
you didn't have anywhere to keep in
contact with your family or family had
to be there his work was so crazy he was
always traveling and my guys are going
with him
no yes we were going with him but then
he would travel from there have you ever
seen these logistics of kids who grow up
in like not structured homes oh you have
you ever looked at statistics now of
kids who don't that like kids who move
you know now look uh I think it's the
the one thing most prisoners have in
common I bet they didn't grow up and
stable have no doubt so so then then it
was then you guys hang out and saw in in
in Lebanon come down with hep hep a you
sister will too
that's all good you guys get sick and
and by the way now let's let's finally
get evacuated not leave but we'll get
evacuated from Lebanon because the wars
full rage or unstable home life effects
unstable homeland Allah then you go to
Greece we'll go to Greece for a couple
years two and a half years and then
we'll go to Saudi Arabia and then you go
to Saudi Arabia hold on spend three
years in Saudi Arabia maybe and then now
you're gonna go to way to boarding
school but we're gonna stay in Saudi
Arabia so I went to boarding school
first time in the United States fourteen
years old I'm in boarding school I'm in
Massachusetts never lived the United
States go to the woods of Massachusetts
I don't had a I didn't know how to put
an address on the envelope yeah I was so
[ __ ] weird and I was such a foreigner
that but I'll give you an example so so
my parents were still in Saudi Arabia
now I'd grown up in the Middle East for
eight years of my life that was mainly
right so in the Middle East when your
friends you hold hands give me your hand
when you go there as your buddy you hold
hands like this or you lock fingers like
seems normal not considered gay it's
just considered what guys do right
America
yep so while we're gonna go to soccer
I'm in a dorm I'm in the United States
I'm around All American tiny sports in
across seas I'm just really just judo
nothing now nothing I never didn't have
sports they didn't have organized sports
you dead secret there's some yeah
there's just pee I played baseball
playing baseball played some baseball so
um so I am I friend Emmanuel he was my
roommate and as we went to go to you
know soccer I I put my I grab if you
just walk in and rads
because he's my new friend and then I
went sorry I was like that's weird so
then I snake my arm around the small of
his waist I'll never forget this he goes
we don't do that here
I was like sorry whatever I guess you
don't [ __ ] either either I guess
guess I'm not gonna get each other off
he was about to win some games [ __ ] I'm
homesick I can't bang you Jesus and that
was yeah that was and then that was
boarding school and then in the summers
I come back to - I go to summer camp in
Wolfeboro Massachusetts oh you don't
like the Hampshire you're I just you
just moved around when I was saying when
I was a 33 years old I believe his 33
was the first time I put a painting or
anything on a wall that's how I lived
man so so that does [ __ ] you ever talk
to a real therapist about it yeah I did
the same thing of it some guys do
someone I didn't man I'm sure I would
but what what so okay so ready so so I
have a problem with stability I have a
problem you know so so what happens you
want people to like you right away cuz
you don't wanna be lonely so you're in a
new place well I'm a stand-up comic what
a surprise what a surprise that I now
make a living staying in front of
strangers and going I'm gonna make you
laugh who's not same [ __ ] the actors are
the other you're playing somebody else
same [ __ ]
so you know it's funny cuz I would try
to write when I would write and my
friend is a writer would critique my
writing and you know he said he said
you're such a good writer the problem is
you have no place he said you don't ever
have a middle ground
so all writers write from place yeah no
place yeah and you have no reference
yeah it's really interesting now I think
I could do it without ya but it's pretty
interesting
yeah damn it's great that weird man so
so I don't want my kids to grow up that
way I'm very grateful I grew up that way
because it made me you know I think it's
part of my talent it's part of how I
make a living probably but it's it is it
is very it's very difficult not to I was
very nervous as a bowling thing xiety
yeah I had a lot of anxiety a lot a lot
a lot it was really weird
never drugs I never had to do that in
her you know but I did back then you
just were just
yeah yeah it's still pretty wacky yeah
yeah I am
it's interesting you guy man you're
young do you think yeah young you think
mister no healthy oh yeah you'll feel
all right good
no but therapy like I like I was
thinking about that I think therapy's
very valuable but what would so they
teach me about what like about maybe
things you're not seeing yeah
like everyone has blind spots so huge
blind spots you have huge blind sure but
I'm you know I've never set I've sat
down and with a therapist with another
person yeah I've never done it just one
on one like it did benefit off it you
know you now and Michael Phelps like the
poster boy because he went solved their
bricks because I think he suffers from
depression it's kind of thing to do
these days anyways he's there's an app
now where he can like FaceTime with a
therapist which i think is brilliant cuz
that's one of the reasons people don't
do it because a you don't know where to
go be it's inconvenient so now you know
if you can just do it on your face time
yeah I will say though I know people
have been through years and years of
therapy and worked hard at it they're
not any better off like I don't slow
down I don't I'm not either I don't
think you can ever I don't think you can
fix the problem I think you're more of
aware of what the re the repercussions
let me ask you I'm saying like so you
realized that this like every time
someone says this you do this I call
[ __ ] so now when someone says that yeah
you know I agree with that like I heard
Henry Rollins saying on Roman shows if
someone says something to you personal
and you take I think it was ten you're
on some I've been sent off but if
someone says something whether they're
correcting your grammar you know when we
first started hanging out you correct my
grandma all the time they were saying if
you take offense to that like take it
personal you have a real issue the ego
issue yes well obviously you just trying
to help
right Mara I keep saying certain things
like bull you say this and I'd like
[ __ ] get mad yeah but then
eventually I was like oh yeah thanks
dude yeah because I knew that you your
job was now gonna be on behind a mic so
even before yeah I gotta help you out
when I was five I see something broken I
gotta you know but I think it's things
like that mean maybe therapists can
point to that direction but I agree with
you some people have been therapy for
and we have butyl friends here who've
been
in it for like they go religious like I
go to the gym like that's my therapy so
yeah it's like they go every week three
four times a week and they're talking to
problems on their bassy best friends
that they're paying a lot of money sure
but then they analyze the world that's a
completely different way like yeah I
just got the they talk in those terms
yes it's a therapist yes but you need
action whoa
and by the way I also think that first
of all when you have good friends and
they you you you can be helped with a
lot of your issues because they can if
they're honest with you you can work
through them at one times sometimes you
can also work through your insurance can
help you know but when you when you're
also you're trying to get better at
something whatever it might be sometimes
you you you can't help but take stock of
how you're coming across yeah and then
you can ask your questions why but Joe
and I were talking about Rogan and I
were talking about how as we've gotten
older yes or we're getting both old
we're getting better at not identifying
emotionally with a point of view so in
other words here's an idea I have right
and I could say it so I could say I
believe in small government and I think
I'm not a let light I think a lot of the
left-wing have the wrong idea whatever
it might be and I'd be emotional about
it and now we heated about yeah now what
I gotta do is I know this is just an
idea that I'm gonna defend I'm gonna
look at it it's a perspective what do
you think of this idea and then we can
have a discussion about it put it out
there though and it's really hard to do
but that comes from maturity and comes
from being aware of how it used to be
versus how I'd like to be and so I think
sometimes you can make it change but
having said that you're right I think a
lot of times in relationships
I got triggers I'm a pain in the ass I
don't know how to not go fly off the
handle in certain circumstances I don't
know how to not become nasty when I'm
fighting though I don't know how why do
I feel insecure about that like why do I
have those why do I have those triggers
right well maybe a therapy can help you
with that kind of see you know I don't
know I don't know I don't know it's it's
all a work in progress as a human being
I think too when you're fighting with so
much to you what I what we do supposed
on the show like I'm trying to get a
rise out of you or the audience so I
talk in extreme huh you and I've always
done so I talking to absol
lose yes do I believe it and play not I
talk to maps I go whatever you're gonna
do I want to try and Trump that to a yes
power so it makes you laugh or people
like that's so ridiculous you talk about
it that's the world I live in sure so
that carries over the personal line you
can get in trouble for something I'm
like cool then I say this it's an
absolute but it's also most people
arguing or make points in this range I
live in this range of this range I live
over here yes I'm trying to get a
reaction yes well I had a really really
interesting experience at 51 this was
kind of humbling where I was talking to
Peter Thiel who is a smart man like you
know just like he's brilliant do you
remember in Silicon Valley where they
have that guy who was like sesame seeds
he was the weird guy I don't want to
kill no this is amazing shows on the
actor actually died but there's this guy
was brilliant and he's like this huge
like tech billionaire it's based on
Peter Thiel yeah and I was talking to
Peter Thiel at this dinner and I was I
was giving my perspective on the
subjects that came up so it was
political subjects or cultural subjects
and I realized that I would say
something in a lot of my a lot of what I
was saying was based on [ __ ] I dread
should I'd been told for sure died her
on podcast and when I did it I put it
all together right looked at the wrong
nothing wrong gonna do the research
enough said oh no and jump in the lab
but but here's the difference between
him and Peter me and Peter teal Peter
teal was coming up with kind of original
concepts and constructs Peter teal was
saying [ __ ] in ways I'd never heard and
I was like this [ __ ] is such a
does he's such an original thinker that
those original thinker it's like the way
we are with comedy where you can own the
original [ __ ] he does that with thoughts
yeah it was just really interesting I
was like oh passed away no no the actor
who played halls
oh Jessica he's my age he's 50 I was
just saying looks all right there he's
so smart I was so blown away I had
actually been around anybody tact with
my dues or he has a fun he's a venture
capitalist he was he's one of the main
investors in I don't know Facebook you
know he's a do kids got more more money
than God for real 2.2 billion is that if
it's actually more than that
apparently he's got three billion
dollars after after a billion does it
matter does it matter
I'm a 2.6 billion a billion seconds is
33 years so he's got two point six of
those so do the math it's two thousand
million no three I know his name cuz he
provided the finance support to hold
Cogan yes he's the one who's [ __ ] well
Gawker outed him and he was like really
and they were nasty about it he goes
okay so when when they when they
released the sex tape for Hulk Hogan he
got behind it he was like all right I'm
gonna finance this and we're gonna ruin
you then he don't know he's over there's
reason he got to where he is don't [ __ ]
around you know he did just that
oh he's usually I was at the is that the
IMP change of subject guys did the
improv last night
and you're I don't know him personally I
know he's boys with Adam right Adam ray
goes on the road with him all the time
but Adam Devine yeah he's get ready to
shoot his Netflix special and he closed
last night so I went on right before him
and he closed last night and I stayed
around to watch his set because you know
I'm a huge fan of workaholics and I've
seen him all this other stuff dude that
[ __ ] had me rolling I I was like
[ __ ] man
that's good it was so funny cuz he's
silly he's the faces he is making like
oh he's silly like us he's silly is
[ __ ] let's get him on the podcast yeah
we need to let's get him on the podcast
he's up good you guys - how old is
tension twenties 16 years old he looked
16 right he's young I think he might
have just gotten married didn't he
34 no okay not that young not that young
but he's a bunch of movies up it was he
from originally he was the warrant
Waterloo Alaska Iowa Iowa interesting
new Iowa yeah him and his boys did that
workaholics which is a [ __ ] brilliant
show never saw it never saw one episode
D'Elia was on there mm-hmm bunch of
people on there
those three guys did their their movie
together that was on I think came out
theaters or Netflix but well workaholics
I was my [ __ ] man that stuff was so
funny
really those guys are so [ __ ] funny
look at that
it's a three of them they're like three
best friends then working the shitty
office space and they're just
knuckleheads who's that kid with the
long hair I've never seen he's hilarious
all three of them are really really good
hmm yeah Adam last night man well you
gather sized play canvas 33 34 37 it's
awesome they saw some times coming for
us all guys huh huh you're 34 now 34 35
Wow when you're older oh wait when I met
you red
well what is that man hey so when with
chechik Ultimate Fighter season 14 this
is gonna be it's gonna freak me out I
want to find out how I do or that I was
lose track of time me too dude I do too
I don't people like I was May whatever I
never did I never did see number 21st
2011
I met tryouts March I met Bryan in 2011
Wow Wow Damon and I need to go yeah
wait that's business team that will hold
on that's not it that's uh Jason Miller
see if it's season 15 you Shane Carwin
Roy Nelson
I'll just put your name well no that's
gonna be a do you ever Google so two
ultimate fighter
Carwin verse Nelson there you go
but my name is gonna say season ten bro
Oh 2012 yeah that's a really seven years
that's in 2012 and then we started
podcasting a ye know let probably six
months after that probably yeah probably
like about that yeah I wonder where
those original ones are I have them
somewhere oh because people ask me all
the time was the original ones I don't
know I'd love to hear those so what I
so hopefully someone can send us those
yeah I remember we did a Colin with
Whitney Cummings yeah it sounds like she
was in a helicopter um yeah that's
old-school me we do at your house on the
[ __ ] UH the max - zoom
no video nothing the producer you guys
named Brian yeah Brian uploaded a column
with Ronda Rousey was back in the day
man that's cool man oh it's cool [ __ ]
yeah cuz I met you on the Ultimate
Fighter set because Nate Marquardt Bret
you actually it made by the way it may
have in 2011 because that's when fired
yet air 2012 but I think we I think we
met in 2011 on the Wikipedia there's no
Jeff on it yeah it's old school man
don't let feel forever ago yeah I'm
[ __ ] flies man dude I quit track like
like someone like I can't believe it was
only two years I've been doing stand-up
yeah feel like you mean for seven years
well you've come a long damn way I'll
tell you that much but even when the
someone's I go to the comic store Texas
or someone tagging something like holy
[ __ ] it's been two years told you dude
you've only been doing it for two years
a very short period of time I can't wait
to see what you're doing in four years
the Altima fighter 16 terrible season
Neil Magny came off this season though
mm-hmm and Sam Alvey other than that you
know what I didn't realize it recently
so almost all the fighters come out of
tough what do you mean the the people on
the on the roster for the UFC most of
them all saw them come out no don't do
that I don't know no that's not true
okay no I mean there's you know a good
crop of them kind of get a chance but I
won't say the majority of them
especially these days but I'm you know
the they're finding Talent I mean I'm
sure there's a good amount that do but
they get him out of different fight
leagues I guess yeah but I'm sure a good
amount come from the Ultimate Fighter
cuz you got you know if you're if you
even get a look at the Ultimate Fighter
means you're on their radar so and then
from there
hmm Bisping came out of there Dillashaw
came out of there were shod Kenny floor
and Forrest Griffin damn that for that
fight that made Forrest Griffin famous
was great who did he fight well now let
me do you see famous it did yeah that
was the boom for this was it really oh
yeah wow I was on spiky was calling
their buddy saying hey you got a look at
this and then it like there's a boom for
them Forrest Griffin and they're still
there I can't believe there's they're
doing this but they decided to carry on
with Ultimate Fighter but set of two
seasons they're going one season now why
because it's it has not been the ratings
of show so [ __ ] tear when the show is
just its ran its course it's on twenty
seven seasons doing anything let's see
that twenty seven seasons now nothing
nicer who's done the right way no but it
just gets old you know and and now like
let's say I'm a manager and I have a
young fighter I would tell them do not
go on the Ultimate Fighter why cuz you
get trapped in a shitty contract that
you have to do and they time you a six
seven fight deal and let's say seven
fights in let's take my case my career
three fights in I'm fighting Gabriel
Gonzaga where if I wonder if came off
the Ultimate Fighter you're giving me a
perennial top fifteen guy I didn't get
paid like that I can renegotiate if I'm
not there fighter I can't do anything
they only for those amount of fights
till I outlive that contract or out
fight that contract right and also it
you almost get you fly under the radar
on the Ultimate Fighter now no one
watches it no one's watching
no one's tuning into it you're better
off just jumping straight into UFC you
better off make a name for yourself in
the regional circuit developing the
skills and then how did Connor come in
how did he get use a multi-time champion
other divisions there's other leagues
outside of the youth hey they were like
let's bring this F kidding
yep that's the way to do it these days
the Ultimate Fighter used to be the
golden take it but not anymore
interesting I wonder what's going on at
Connors head I wonder like he's got to
fight this monster
he's been away how many days yeah fight
two years I'm sure I'll never may you
know fight in the UFC in the USA but he
you know he fought last year against
Floyd Mayweather
yeah but they didn't make the other foxy
have fought since 2000 16 November yeah
so be two years about time you question
how does he deal with all the noise but
he's been dealing with it pretty well
yeah because wasn't the biggest fight of
the century against Floyd Mayweather
yeah nerves and stuff yeah yeah that's
kind of what he does yeah yeah got some
current events buddy sure the first one
is the one that Brendan posted yesterday
Bryce Mitchell his injury with the power
drill and he ripped his nut how does it
happen
yeah my favorite party goes zombie out a
little bit so I was gonna train today
but I ripped my nutsack in half I'm
about to get stitched up I was holding a
board over my head with a drill in my
pants
I was sizing up the board and the drill
went off and tangled my nuts up in it
I dropped the board to reverse the drill
and untangled my nut sacks but they but
they was ripped in half I'm serious too
lol I obviously can't post a pic but
when my nuts are sealed back up I'm
gonna come train again I think a high
kick would rip them rip them haha and if
I hear any shitty puns about how this
whole thing is nutty or screwed up I
talk to me for about a month if you're
gonna drop a pun and make fun of me at
least put some thought into it
hello ever have but then he posted a
picture of me I did send him some
underwear but at least he posted a
picture of his underwear like that oh no
what what um what it's bro we're on
these every night now I was gonna say
from the 90s well weights you find out
I'm gonna guess was he a lightweight I
look right now
goddamn that's socks how'd it go off in
your paper had it go off in your pants
no I sure am I sure have you ever have
you ever dipped it up like some about
Mary style I probably is a little kid
yeah on my nutsack 145 40 huh 144 145 um
you you zipped it up huh yeah I'm Arab
being terrible oh my god it's so tender
that's it I have
I've taken a manscape a little bit Oh me
just shave shave the ol nose and I
caught him oh there's that it is a mob
lead instantly oh it's a [ __ ] they
just believe Oh cutting your bed are so
tender don't cut your back a few a few
things that just the body isn't meant to
be hit your nuts and fill it one day
chin and your eyes your nuts in your
eyes you're not there so tries to show
the inside of your knee though right
there that's a real there's a bone
that's alright but I'd rather get my
[ __ ] knees with a bat than my nuts or
eyes that's like your eyes are so yeah I
mean dude Toki the eye god damn that
hurts your afflictive this this they're
like you if I do this to you are
whatever broke you did it to my face
ball whatever you hit me in the eye but
you flick my eye I'm like ink oh my god
yeah you flick my nuts or this you can
flick my shaft I'm like whatever bro
bring it but you flick the tip of it
brings me my knee my father-in-law got
out of the water ease and with my son my
son has the hose full blast on and my
son's I have my father my gos ha gang
right in your eye about an intimate old
- his retina I can't see anything detach
this right goddamn yeah yeah yeah it's
surgery I had to get surgery
oh man with my son yeah it sounds like
there you go writing is just a [ __ ]
fire hose right to the eye and my father
was so tough yeah that's retinas no joke
real terrible injury uh nuts or eyes man
Jinni every I wanna say no gonna poke
any eyes I feel like it'd be poke to be
tough to poke you guys why bro look at
look at everyone this room you yeah I'm
for sure the most like get poked in the
eyes of like you know big eyes whatever
your face big guys it's me pretty easy
to poke my eyes chin hook like this you
know it's like he's gonna one like this
it's got a wide face hello
how are you even poked in the eye
I'll get punched in the eye never poked
oh right no but I didn't see the Punch
coming so it did hit my my ball but you
never been poked in the eye poked poked
you know poke when you get a poke I
poked myself in the eye hmm so it's
really poaching I know it's too hard
especially if I was laughs your ass and
little like it's like it's like it's
like a [ __ ] bullseye on a dartboard
bro can't get it around here you're
gonna score some point uh-huh you want
the homerun y'all hit chin right square
in the eye man happened here and poked
him that you ready to hit in the nuts or
poke that I feel I feel sorry for you
bro always about you and I getting in
the ring there's so much noise we have
to do it from roots of fire anyone I do
it we do you know roots fight released a
hundred more limited edition shirts by
the way chin Brian vintage fight poster
tease I'll do it in the sheet back a
calm
you should doing the shirts in the shirt
this thing there's a vote going on 4,000
votes it's up in the air 50/50 there's
no one knows I'm 50/50 nobody knows J
shop thinks Brian beat the [ __ ] out of
me goes dude you see the votes are you I
did see it 50v I see it makes sense no
one really knows what to expect
Ringwraiths would be a [ __ ] we'd
have no idea what Brian has we have no
idea you have like yeah I have no idea
chins either be terrible or wheezing
surprise the [ __ ] out of us we don't
know I see that I don't know I don't
know we're very mysterious we're gonna
get it we're gonna get it with and then
I told you I said 50/50 J cos I think
Brian beats Church it will do three
rounds three two-minute rounds be great
what I thought was 1 minute rounds one
minute that tough man bro we're gonna
three two-minute rounds don't worry
about it one man can find out that
before one day we came and get in the
groove bro it's tiring but it'll be fine
two minutes yes three too many rods
people come on it man I booked Donnie
I've been trying to set it up for a
while you guys need to do it on [ __ ]
barstools rough and rowdy bro but
they're gonna want us to tear each
other's heads out there boys
well have some fun
getting into [ __ ] no we are we said
we'll do it
it's got it make it happen you want to
do it we'll get cameras and just do it
be great do it's a fight thing I'll do
it next week yeah next week now give it
a give it a little give it two weeks
from now you must do anyone he needs one
two weeks you want to October they give
enough to love the weather in October so
that's not perfect creepy [ __ ] man
October I love other October cuz the
leaves falling anyways yeah I guess
October try and do an October let's see
if it happens I'm so down you chin you
know you want to get this thing - you
gotta post videos of you training so
people actually believe you I'll get a
membership to a gym after this dude I
can hook you up a box and burn cinema
it's too it's too like my class yeah
I'll learn rather just go someone boxing
gyms downtown there's a shitload there's
one over here not a boxing gym just a
national gym just go work out you need a
box bro I got stuff you squat hurry for
a box man do that we're happy other
tournaments gents I got a few have you
guys seen John Cena lately no my god I
saw this picture now does he do all the
steroid he looks ridiculous look at this
he looks like he's usually he's usually
like the smooth jacked he's [ __ ] why
would he do that be well he looks great
when he's not he's going back out huh
going back wrestling some wrestling
stuff ramp he's going back to dojo ve
watched check this out because he does a
bunch of look at his tits right any man
who can stand and walk in the same
sentence has got something figured out I
just got some news for you
wrong place wrong time for everyone else
in the world on the ww2 zonker
the place and time you wanna be the WWE
super show down my partner
the unstoppable bobby lashley and you
know very few times in my life have I
been viewed as a secret weapon but I no
longer have a target on my back I've
been in hiding I've been dropping a few
pounds I'm quicker faster and not only
am i a secret but I have a secret weapon
WWE Universe prepare yourselves for 20
tall he's great but he's got tits I hate
him so awkward I know he knows it you
know
well him and Bobby last year me partners
you've seen Bobby Lashley he looks good
he looks probably so they so human body
lasting babies get trying to get shred
to look like Bobby laughs looks good
dude I don't like his face like that oh
he looks like just like boulders oh my a
bunch of boulders
he's my training partner for three years
he was oh yeah what do you mean legit
MMA fighter oh he is yeah can wrestle
his ass oh I remember that guy national
champion in the army I think wrestling
East super beast freak out look at the
super I don't care if you want to keep
that man of steroids with him all the
time what was that one train with me and
chain he is a [ __ ] freak how big is
he he's not tall he's just [ __ ] she's
very very lean and [ __ ] shredded did
you hat hold wrong with him in what
aspect my striking was a lot better okay
a my jujitsu but his wrestling was
ridiculous I've never seen anything up
ever you've never seen him get taken out
no ass Josh Brener him and Josh Burnett
trading partners for years Josh can grab
his ass off never took my cannot believe
what he looks he looks like a bunch of
balls she want me know we could take he
look like just a bunch of balls his
nickname should be Bobby bunch of balls
Bobby's a bowling ball he's got bowling
balls everywhere who took all who
stacked all the bowling balls
that's a cool spoiling ball sculpt chat
Simon to the best picture and there's
better ones
look at those traps do I have a huge
scar down my back literally like like
someone took a samurai sword and hit me
across the back like a whip because he
had long nails and we arrested him so
sweaty and we're going round after round
and he's trying to snap me down take me
down and he slipped and his middle
finger nail just right down my back to
my coach goes whoa whoa whoa stop and my
blood all down the back of my
I couldn't feel it and I'm like what he
goes dude you're [ __ ] back as nails
dude how tossing huh six one maybe is he
was he stronger than you
very modest you're very strong [ __ ]
strong but are you and also the nicest
guy you ever meet I bet the nicest guy
in the world thank God and then you know
obviously you've been wrestling like WWE
and outside of that for like this Pro
Wrestling forever that's been his thing
than fighting in Japan writing it all
over Wow well when you again he's
another guy where you know he's not only
CM Punk's he's a guy like Brock Lesnar
who has her background in legit
wrestling sure happens to be a freak
athlete went into the WWE the I don't
know how long he was in Devon define MMA
he's still fighting it with me oh yes
okay so six three in where where where
was he fighting MMA
he's a belt or inna forty five pounder
yeah wow it's got a lot of wins there
yeah yeah tough [ __ ] diamond I buy
that's a tough tough guy he looks like
again a lot of people want make the
comparisons but I don't know if they do
but the CM Punk so no no no no no no the
jet fighters nah he's 42 to strikings
not amazing but his wrestling is we did
Ari dick you know 442 shredded Jesus I'm
gonna go on I've decided that maybe I'll
go on TRT I want to do steroids and get
huge if God even I don't there's not a
steroid on this planet can make you look
like but Nelson no you'd look more like
John Cena if he had like.he I was
listening to this guy Romano cuz I
cameras less at first he's the steroid
guru right really smart card no really
smart guy Ramana I watched a fittest man
on earth I'll find it I watched fittest
man on earth
and I'm jacking off to then and yeah
well no cuz it's all the CrossFit people
yeah I know that's look at the men the
women in there is right there that
they're steroids in CrossFit featuring
Johnny Romano
smart smart guy is about right that
little scene for me but I get such a
kick out of listening on the cross the
top CrossFitters say that they they're
not twink
it's just insane I know I thought it
seemed saying they're on it no he was
he's going he goes if you don't believe
that he's so sure these household names
or art yeah that's it he's so that was
it Jen yeah I was just audio that's fine
yeah that's why it's only audio it's a
podcast okay you know it's it's
virtually anonymous but I you know I
have no problem admitting that over half
of my clientele in any given time are
CrossFit athletes whose main goal is to
pass the drug test at them at the the
regionals I guess I guess the question
that everyone would want to know then is
are these household names or are they
like are these people that people would
know or they like the people that nobody
would actually find out about anyway
like you know are these the Tiger Woods
and the you know Michael Jordan's or the
Tiger Woods mark you know what lacrosse
tree becomes is the the guy that's in
second place is always the guy that
works the hardest right if the guy
that's in first time true he works as
hard as he has to do to win it seems
like after conjugate to works doing this
it's not the guy that's the first place
that's laying on the ground you know
half beaten to death it's the guy that
got second and third so you know some
would make the argument and I've heard
this argument said that the top guys
aren't doing anything because these are
the guys that are already there they
continue to make it and it's everyone
else that's trying to jump on to that
response place that will do anything to
make it there is a super close together
that's that's I guess if you believe in
the Easter Bunny you can believe in that
too he's great Johnny Romano across he's
the guy I wanna if I ever go on TRT or
Sara's I'm calling that dude really yeah
he knows so much that like he was the
bigger faster stronger I mean he knows
his [ __ ] I feel like you talked to our
boys who provided the kratom they know
this [ __ ] he's the guy he's that he's he
was the guy that that they went to yeah
I mean he's he was the editor-in-chief
of flex magazine he knows his [ __ ] he
makes the steroids he's he's like I he
knows how to help all the athletes get
away with it but if you talk to him he's
like top pro sports they do you know
they're doing you're you're using peds
performance
enhancing drugs when steroids is an
umbrella term for a lot of things you
know but it was really interesting to
hear him talk about it um did anyone
need to listen Johnny Romano
no what I was saying is that when I
watch this thing the CrossFitters were
so holier-than-thou about they're like
well if you kook cheat you're a piece of
[ __ ] I was like those are the guys who
had all the girls remember Lance
Armstrong right wait so it's gel so
these guys good you got you got to do
the women have abs like they're both
damp like a human growth hormone stomach
I'm not taking anything away from what
they do is incredible like what the the
amount of effort and dedication and
every way is incredible but let's not be
that judgmental of steroids when you're
doing them you know it was just really
weird but I guess I guess they have a
lot to lose so but you're right I mean
you're right you see these guys like
Lance Armstrong and stuff like that or
all of them and they're just so indicial
right just about the people are so
holier-than-thou it's like yeah come on
so obvious tell me that much about [ __ ]
you know the colonel vention MMA one
sure all righty I don't if you guys
already know but you already said UFC
230 because of a orbital injury to do it
I gotta be honest too for Yoel it's not
a terrible thing like him fighting palo
cup coast is there's nothing for him for
Paula coaster it's a huge opportunity
that's not gonna happen so it sucks for
Paulo but for Yoel I I never got why he
would take the fight and I mean
obviously he's a warrior you know fight
whoever but it didn't make much sense
you'd only be fighting for title shot
you only be fighting big names and
obviously they're just trying to build
Costa here and see where coast is that I
thought it was too much too soon for
Costa I thought it was a no-win
situation for Yoel I'm not I wanted to
watch the fight I think it's
entertaining fight it doesn't it I
didn't see it benefiting either done hmm
unless Costa goes in there and starches
him and then he's [ __ ] catapulted to
the top of the division which I and who
knows if he's ready for that would have
been a really fun fight though yep for
us yeah and isn't great yeah what else
you get all right so I think you guys
know who Big Boi is locally if you're
from Los Angeles you know him from I
love Big Boy power 106 knives at 92.3 so
he got hit by a drunk driver and the
crazy thing about this is after the
drunk driver hit him he took out a vodka
starts Wiggin so I'll show ya boy did
know they got a hit big boy Oh word so
this kind of car is the drunk driver
it's not me no he's still in the car but
check it out so the guy in the BMWs the
drunk driver yes
is that a BMW yeah that's being done
3-series not checking out here he's just
swinging on vodka no he's the old dude
things haven't worked out for me yes so
the crazy thing about this is they found
out he's a prosecutor for Los Angeles
County District Attorney's Office what
district office luck well why did you
say B would cut with his pants down
though both so this guy was called his
pants down when the cops got there his
pants just dropped to the ground okay
the prosecutors file he's having a hard
time having a very hard time yeah Wow
that's a guy that's a guy who's probably
had rock bottom there okay so be a big
boy remember his name was yeah boy he
was huge he was one of the good ones man
yeah
yes great guy yeah I see him periodic
Mayo - really really good guy yeah I've
seen him say hi to you how do you know
him
hidin but I don't know we just been
passing he's always great to good people
yeah he has MMA fighters on the show too
does he yeah big boy let's do this man I
love big boy yeah he's a good guy he
left he's on the main one 105 nine and
left it did somehow on a six ninety two
point three three yeah okay I just was
hammered and you know what he doubled
down one you know what [ __ ] just
finished the bottle yeah or do you think
that's a technique because he is a
prosecutor so what if he knows what he's
doing what if he was drunk right and
then he crashed but then after he
crashed he started drinking like oh I
drank after I crashed lucky what if he
did that on purpose no it doesn't work
that way because you got open container
in your car so your thought could they
prove that he drank beforehand and also
take your blood alcohol level no I mean
after the crash you drink you know I'm
saying it doesn't matter I don't know it
might be the test guy that's wrong [ __ ]
clearly so he was on leave of absence
since January 1st 2017 Wow have a heart
you know mistakes like that can really
cost you everything it's really tough
I'd be a tough one
yeah Jesus did he [ __ ] up big boys
entire car they didn't show big boys car
headed Nissan Armada
he knows big boy did yeah yeah why he
what Nissan Oh big boys been sleeping a
long time big drug big big SUV well
there's what else you got alright are
you guys fans of post Malone yes so he
was at the VMAs and then we was flying
back his jet his private jet two tires
blew on the left side of his jet so they
had to do an emergency landing with
Poland he won song of the year he's like
what the biggest rap artist in the world
he's from Texas his story's actually
pretty cool
he's from Texas he's like a normal dude
who [ __ ] with face tattoos thing now
they're growing more that's why all the
kids are doing the thing welcome hey I
do not understand Kevin Hart made
funnies like it can get quick and
[ __ ] face that it's a terrible idea
Kevin Roberts a you [ __ ] you
better hope this [ __ ] works out this
entertainer works out for you doesn't
good luck getting job them face that
booze it's literally a trend right now
going on with all the like whatever and
their lilz yeah but his is his are funny
cuz says always tired under each eye oh
he's dead his story is pretty
interesting if you look into it what is
it
I owe it very vaguely but I know he's
from Texas and he's telling parents he's
gonna make it if he doesn't you know
like he bet on himself and he [ __ ]
not only did he make it but he's
literally besides Drake he's [ __ ] up
there for the biggest friend don't face
tattoos they're so stupid like career
beginnings where is that scroll up a
little bit where it says huh
kind of puts him on his stage name was
for it because he grew up he wanted to
be an artist right so he got into
country and he was in a band
he learned guitar playing guitar hero
it's pretty cool man his story so he's
playing guitar hero post always had a
love for emo music
he was a DJ there you go CBN well when
he's in a heavy metal band soon after he
says he transition to softer rock as
well as hip-hop before began experiment
in FL studio at 16 using audacity post
created his first mixtape young and
after them riches he showed it to some
of his classmates at grapevine high
school he's voted most likely become
famous by his classmates in senior
he worked at chicken Express that
teenager he enrolled at a community
college but dropped out after leaving
college post moved to Los Angeles where
his with his longtime friend
professional gamer Crenna post chose the
name yeah so batesy he's just like this
yeah
Brett not even rags-to-riches cuz your
normal high school white kid from Texas
was playing guitar here it's a white kid
which more Latin know he's white is why
he's super white huh couldn't get any
whiter from Texas
well Texas he could definitely be I'm
just saying he's like go straight white
dude from Texas Wow
his musics are actually pretty good I
like him because he doesn't act like
he's not trying to act like a thug or
like a gangster rapper and he talks
about like his new CD like his
influences are like Kurt Cobain like
Nirvana Foo Fighters then hip-hop like
he tries to combine all that stuff Wow
I'll see he looks like an [ __ ] his
Styles extra pretty good he's insanely
out of shape if there's a lot of drugs
but this styles I don't know if it's his
style is but his style in his genre for
his lane is [ __ ] dope huh yeah so
he's playing the [ __ ] tires maybe
play a song I'll show you I think what's
interesting post Malone goes I made it
safely cuz I can't believe somebody you
[ __ ] selfish [ __ ] were wishing
death on me yeah he's getting all these
people like I hope you're playing [ __ ]
crashes I hope you die he's like Jesus
Christ man that's terrible I know just
haters I'm successful that's what
happens when you see the actual landing
though it didn't look too crazy so
that's where it's landing when you have
no wheels though it's pretty [ __ ]
secured I know especially those private
jets those crabs Branson Landing
there's another angler here that's the
air traffic control audio that looks
normal play a song for Brian I play one
of his top go back that YouTube page you
just done I don't know
no I was so slow although that didn't
went song of the year let me see what
else they got let me have the one I'm in
the one song no hold on get rid of those
tattoos there just can't bro there
Terrell Double Down scroll down rocked
off the rock stars [ __ ] big 396
million views gonna click on that 396
that's how crazy these new artists are
man so much support base with 21 savage
another guy tattoos on his face
but he's from Atlanta just take it in B
take it in I got the dad man dad shoes
on I got my short shorts do your
psoriasis is popping pop lock and drop
it
a lot of blood [ __ ] hoes and Papa
Millie's feeling like a rock star sure
he looks like a vampire big deal sure he
looks like an extra off True Blood big
deal not that dad not the duck dive this
is what's hot right now be welcome to
2018 bro I'm gonna face that too bro oh
well who are your kids well did it
change at all did he change what I mean
the music
now he's gonna flow for you if you don't
mind now his facial here little thin for
me little little rat like some would say
very few up on myself I'll be honest
with you I'm a post Malone fan bro there
you go bro that's why I do this I want
to educate you are other older elders
come out 21 Sam sighs MA okay well
that's that'd be okay
now here comes 21 savage tell me if I'm
doing this - they're fighting look look
all right well like I'm opening doors
okay like your future's so bright you
got to open doors yeah and look right
now
what's that I'm walking through the
world blind cuz I don't care oh yeah now
what's this what's that
blowing kisses to the face oh [ __ ] now
here's twenty one side show me what you
think him he's at a two in the middle of
his face
damn yeah twenty what's up one down is
he big too he's huge
dude me and my brother were watching
that when we're in the hotel I forget
what city were in but we went to Drake's
YouTube page
your drink's YouTube page how each video
has like three billion views like the
amount of money he must make up just
YouTube aware how rich people are what
do you think about that you know what
much we make up YouTube which is [ __ ]
take how much he makes like Drake's
[ __ ] 91 million views 243 million
views like how about how about the one
video so 787 million views he just
walked around and gave it a like a
million dollars to all people in the
streets of Miami that that was the music
video there's him just giving out
millions of dollars to printable well a
million and and what did what did the
shitty people do to him what's a million
bro how you just read about a million
he's like what the [ __ ] that's crazy but
just look at some of the like all the
millions of views is not it's kind of
crazy now and then how about Ellen was
like oh cool YouTube you want to
capitalize off my fame why must start my
own you have Ellen tube so she just has
their own network that she uploads her
all her [ __ ] - yeah people watch it no
yeah for Ellen good I don't know what
it's Alan tuber typing not on not on
here she has her own [ __ ] her own
[ __ ] Ellen tube or some [ __ ] like
that
mmm but I'm sure we can see how many
views it's getting she just has all our
own [ __ ] into the show views you forget
how Zeke Ellen is like scroll up chin
you missed it to the right there so it
just says month huh I don't say the save
you harder 69 thousand views 69 592
yeah not that crazy for 7,001
still not that critical is hurt 19
seasons Robert 15 seasons
she's big yeah just making real money
well she has her Netflix special coming
out you know that didn't and up stand up
Wow
and guess who helped her right oh boy
Neal Brennan
Wow here's a whole bit on it how you
went to her house okay lofty I mean he
writes for he's brilliant mine
yeah Alan wait cool YouTube doing them
just can do my own shoes called
ellentube alright what else you get chin
alright let's check this oh so this is a
I don't know if you care about this but
Kanye West his sandals to Denny's
they're too small yeah they're just
people are making fun cuz they're too
small what you see him right there goes
there's what do you like those sandals
no I should wides I don't like sandals
is a grown man
I support Kanye and some of his outfits
obviously I'm rocking shoes right now I
don't support a lot of shoes these are
Yeezy dad shoes I don't support sandals
with suits I don't support sandals with
jeans I don't support sandals during the
middle of the day the only time you can
wear sandals is if you're in a beach on
vacation
other than that you cannot wear them
that's our Tara can not wear sandals
Tara grown man and be taken seriously
also no one wants to see your [ __ ]
open toes also chosen so that's too
small they're way too small now I'm not
mad [ __ ] Kim's outfit and at all
Connie's outfits pretty dope until you
put on the [ __ ] sandals with the gray
socks what are you doing and they're too
small I just can't I don't give a [ __ ]
what else gets in um
Batgirl and really with the Nazi husband
oh yeah she finally came out with a
statement she doesn't Nazi tattoo on her
neck no I I want to thank everyone for
their support in kind words over the
past week every post tweet comment does
not go unnoticed my family in our
handling situation miss our ability this
is a very sensitive issue and not one
that as a public figure I wish to not I
wish was not taking place in a public
forum I respectfully ask that everyone
respect our privacy at this time as we
work towards resolutions in closure I
look forward to returning the Octagon
resume
ways in their future oh cool what's the
chance if she gets back with her
boyfriend husband oh yeah whatever those
deep as a deep yeah
oh [ __ ] Mike Channel resigned the belt
or that's big yeah
Kim you know good for him stretch in
this check out this wheel that gets
close to a whale-watching boat let's see
this your standard hell back here yeah
but see the one in the distance that I
looking at that sure sure
alright fun time whoa [ __ ] oh dude
they're so lucky he didn't hit that so
yeah that's as close as it gets I don't
think they realize how lucky they're to
live well there's that there's a guy on
a no boat who was killed on H in Google
or their YouTube whale hits boat kills
everybody there's a there's a YouTube
thing where there's a face of death well
death yeah volume 7 turn on cruise ships
oh this is a yeah this is not one video
that yeah this whale literally well I'm
sure I see from a distance that's it
here yeah you'll see in a second they
record this on their [ __ ] visa well
that would be you wipe the whites the
way I'll hit the boat here's a few girls
that didn't quite how he's coming right
ass whales they're so friendly oh wow
look at all the cute whales yes yes
whales whales for sure hit the boat
whale boat brightly the way up I don't
like units flushing territory bro HM
when they wrecked the [ __ ] boat and
kill everyone
ha there's a little girl on that I think
they're doing there the music's so
dramatic dude I haven't seen one will
[ __ ] bow chin that's versa boat go to
go back there you go
there has to be something better than
this chin did you google worst videos to
watch when trying to find it we've
always tried to be shitty yeah go back
this one
yeah yeah I'm sure dude that is game
over
oh they're on a kayak yeah
oh boy he just pushes them over
[Music]
these videos suction
let's get over this all right I'm trying
to [ __ ] crack in style where they
break the goddamn boat in half like it
damn it
Pirates of the Caribbean - OH - the
whale huh bow obviously they couldn't
really see where they were going they
were driving in the whale decided to
come out of the water a little bit yeah
whales doing well [ __ ] you didn't die
damn boat up bring your boat around oh
man
see oh god damn sperm whale jumping ship
yeah I'm so sperm whale in the open ah
man couple time dude when's the last
thing to a sperm whale a Moby Dick well
yeah you never see him they still around
oh yeah are they stink well how do
people kill no me neither
but when's the last night how come is no
sperm whale week no sure they're
dangerous they eat they eat [ __ ]
squid yeah they do
oh no is this / yes / well so I'm
talking about yeah the only way the only
way a hundred and thirty thousand pounds
one hundred and thirty thousand pounds
that's how much sperm whale weighs 130 a
blue whale's heart is the size of a
Volkswagen bug dude look how cool that
little big stupid faces a stupid face so
your [ __ ] noses eyes like jinae's I
think they live to like for five hundred
years I'm crazy they live 1,000 years oh
yeah no that's real pictures that was
real bro oh [ __ ] great wait
not that much else
well done sperms sure and I'm sparkly
dude I like a nice sperm whalemen guys I
like a nice sperm whale thank you thanks
for coming in in your outfit dude and
your dad shoes sure buddy so it was my
pleasure and I appreciate this and we'll
see you on Monday kids we will see you
guys on Monday and Vancouver I'll see
you September 13th and the 20th through
the 22nd Chicago Schaumburg improv the
week after that I'm in Seattle at the
parlor live get your tickets now at tea
fat K dot-com
and this Sunday I'm with Bobby Lee
I am with Whitney Cummings and we are
doing some serious stand-up at The
Comedy Store main room this Sunday 8
o'clock it's uh it's for pancreatic
cancer so boom and then roots of fight
the chin Kalen shirt vintage boxing
shirt
they just re-released 200 more tea fat
cake ah more give them at roots of fight
Dom get them this is the final kid we're
out yeah